I do want to talk about this story even
though it's still very very early we
don't have all of the information yet
but we do have some some important and
very very disturbing information eleven
victims plus a police officer are dead
along with the shooter at yet another
public mass shooting this one happened
at the borderline Bar and Grill in
Thousand Oaks California very full bar
last night
shooter opens fire kills 11 people as
well as a police officer who was
responding to the incident the shooter
also dead from a self-inflicted gunshot
wound and about a dozen other people
have been injured and police
spokespeople have described the scene as
horrific with blood everywhere the
shooter has been identified it is indeed
another young white male 28 years old
heavily tattooed was part of the initial
description that was released we've now
learned that he was a former US Marine
who showed up with a 45 caliber handgun
which had been reportedly legally
purchased as well as a or multiple smoke
devices at this time once again it's
being reported that the shooter took his
own life not shot by police it's also
been reported that in April of this year
there was an incident involving the
shooter that led to a mental health
evaluation which ended with the shooter
being cleared by mental health experts
and there are some early reports that
some of the people inside at yesterday's
shooting were also at the location at
the the event of the Las Vegas shooting
that happened not that long ago which is
just unimaginable I mean just even
having enough mass shootings that you've
got people who were more than one is
extraordinarily disturbing and we
already know what will happen if and
when the motivations of this individual
become clear if they ever do because we
often don't actually end up getting
clarity if it's a right-winger then it's
just a person who did this for no reason
related to their politics whatsoever if
it's a left-winger as they're already
sort of priming the pump with by saying
was country music night at the bar even
in Thousand Oaks if you go to country
music night you must be a right-winger
meaning the shooter was targeting
right-wingers of course without any
evidence whatsoever at this time if it
is a left-winger they will create a
counter narrative that will completely
ignore the string of right-wing terror
in the United States and it's it's too
early to tell it's very early in the
story but we should put politics
completely aside for a moment if it's
possible and realized that this is just
happening too often because even that
you can't get universal agreement on you
actually see comments online from people
who say country of three hundred and
forty million people even if it's
statistically super safe there are still
going to be lots of these and many
people even refusing to acknowledge that
this is a problem hopefully more
information soon just another absolutely
horrible incident today's show was made
possible in part by simple habit calm
slash Pakman at this point the benefits
of meditation have been pretty clearly
shown to be significant and that's why
I'm so excited that simple habit is
sponsoring the show which is a guided
meditation app that just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app I use the app myself all you need is
5 to 10 minutes a day simple habit lets
your brain go on a quick vacation that
it very likely really needs maybe you've
been thinking about giving meditation a
try you don't know where to start simple
habit is really the perfect way to just
jump right into it great for beginners
equally useful for people with
meditation experience they've got quick
meditations for first thing in the
morning for falling asleep at night for
clearing your mind when you're stressed
meditations for decision-making for
getting motivated getting focused
getting creative hundreds and hundreds
to choose from they're designed and
recorded by well-known names in the
world of meditation and mindfulness and
you can track all of your progress so
whatever time of day it is whatever mood
you're in there's probably a meditation
on simple
habit that's perfectly suited for
whatever you're trying to accomplish
with meditation go check it out you can
try it free for seven days at simple
habit calm slash Pakman I've put a link
underneath this video